[Aplausos]
[Música]
italia es el único país junto a grecia
que es más pobre ahora que cuando entró
en el euro tal cual como lo oís si
seguís visual polític desde hace tiempo
ya sabéis que dentro del equipo que
hacemos posible este canal yo soy el más
europeísta de todos pero en este caso
las cifras son claras
[Música]
estar ya ha salido perdiendo con la
unión europea hablamos de la segunda
potencia industrial de europa sólo por
detrás de alemánia para que os hagáis
una idea en los años 90 los italianos
eran más ricos que los británicos o los
franceses y los que tengáis miedo o
seáis más mayores recordaréis a
raffaella carrá laura pausini o los
juguetes de los ingleses
[Música]
italia ha sido una de las mayores
potencias del planeta y todo esto a
pesar de su gobierno y sus políticos
porque si amigos de visual política la
historia política de este país es cómo
decirlo a su lado juego de tronos parece
la casa de la pradera para que os hagáis
una idea los italianos tienen a la mafia
siciliana la camorra napolitana lanzan
greta calabresa y otras tantas bandas de
crimen organizado y todas ellas tienen
todavía hoy conexiones políticas al más
alto nivel
pero no sólo hablamos de mafia durante
la guerra fría el gobierno italiano
llegó a financiar a grupos terroristas
de extrema derecha que organizaron los
atentados más sangrientos del país y qué
pasa con la extrema izquierda pues
tampoco se quedó atrás las brigadas
rojas secuestraron y asesinaron a nada
menos que un primer ministro es más si
tenéis curiosidad y os gusta el morbo os
recomiendo que busquéis información
sobre la logia propaganda due o que
veáis la película 'el divo de paolo
sorrentino descubriréis un país
fascinante y donde la política es de
todo menos aburrida
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero qué está pasando
ahora en italia siguen las cosas tan
movidas como en los años 70 y 80 pues
podéis juzgar por vosotros mismos en
sólo 10 años
italia ha tenido seis primeros ministros
distintos seis en sólo diez años en
otras palabras que seguirá el día a día
de la política italiana es misión
imposible y por eso en este vídeo no
vamos a centrarnos ni en las elecciones
italianas que se han celebrado
recientemente ni en los escarceos de
berlusconi porque la pregunta más
interesante es cómo es posible que un
país con semejante sistema político
pudiera llegar a ser tan rico y qué pasó
después para que hayan llegado a tener
dos décadas sin crecimiento económico
alguno hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a conocer al
bueno el feo y el malo de la historia
política italiana
[Música]
giulio andreotti es el bueno en los años
40 italia era el país con el partido
comunista más grande de toda europa
occidental tenía más de 1.300.000
afiliados lo que significa que en
cualquier momento podrían ganar unas
elecciones como os podéis imaginar en
plena guerra fría
eeuu estaba dispuesto a hacer cualquier
cosa para evitarlo recordáis el plan
marshall si sois veteranos seguidores de
visual política ya sabéis que el 'tío
sam' mando toneladas de dinero a europa
para que se reconstruyera tras la
segunda guerra mundial
en el caso de italia ese dinero no sólo
servía para ayudar al país sino también
para ayudar al único partido que podía
hacer frente a los comunistas y ese
partido no era otro que la democracia
cristiana
madre y salva a tus hijos del
bolchevismo vota democracia cristiana en
los siguientes 50 años italia tuvo hasta
30 primeros ministros distintos tal cual
como lo oís eso significa que la edad
media de un primer ministro italiano era
de poco más de año y medio pero todos
ellos tenían una cosa en común
prácticamente todos pertenecían a la
democracia cristiana y si hay una
persona que destaca en estos años es
este señor que veis en la pantalla
giulio andreotti
[Música]
un hombre que llegó a ser primer
ministro no una ni dos ni tres sino
siete veces durante décadas
andreotti era algo así como el padrino
de la política italiana prácticamente
cualquiera que quisiera llegar a algo en
la clase dirigente de este país
necesitaba su bendición
el poder desgasta a aquellos que no lo
tienen
giulio andreotti y os preguntaréis pero
que defendía la democracia cristiana
exactamente pues básicamente era un
cóctel ideológico que combinaba todo lo
que no fuera comunismo
eso incluía pactos ocultos con la cosa
nostra siciliana la camorra napolitana y
presuntamente grupos terroristas de
extrema derecha que asolaron el país
durante los años 80 pero de eso
hablaremos en otro vídeo lo cierto es
que tanto la democracia cristiana como
los gobiernos de andreotti necesitaban
asegurarse el apoyo popular las
elecciones no se ganan solas y para eso
que mejor que dar trabajos bien pagados
italia tiene más de 3 millones y medio
de funcionarios y están entre los
mejores pagados del mundo es más desde
los tiempos de andreotti hasta nuestros
días
italia es famoso por dos cosas juzgados
que no funcionan y papeleos
interminables para que os hagáis una
idea vamos a imaginar que tenemos una
empresa que vende maquinaria de
construcción y tenemos un cliente que no
nos quiere pagar lo que nos debe lo
lógico es que lo denunciemos en un
tribunal verdad pues bien este proceso
en un país como francia nos llevaría a
una media de unos dos meses y medio en
italia tendríamos que esperar más de
tres años para que nos resolviera
nuestro problema
como os podéis imaginar este no es y era
el mejor clima para los negocios sin
embargo no hemos dicho que italia llegó
a ser uno de los países más prósperos de
europa como es posible que italia
tuviera empresas tan competitivas pues
mis queridos amigos de visual político
la respuesta está en la liga italiana
tal cual como lo oís al tener su propia
moneda el banco central italiano podía
devaluar la divisa cada vez que
necesitaba poner su economía en
esteroides y os preguntaréis no os
decimos siempre visual polític que eso
es lo contrario a lo que hay que hacer
por ejemplo en este otro vídeo os
contábamos que alemania se hizo rica en
parte gracias a tener una divisa fuerte
como era el marco alemán sin embargo
ahora os estoy diciendo lo contrario
como es esto posible
cómo es posible que italia creciera
tanto pese a las devaluaciones la
corrupción y la burocracia pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
rocco siffredi es el feo los millenials
que veáis este vídeo no tendréis ni idea
de lo que os estoy hablando pero antes
mucho antes de que nacho vidal
conquistar a las pantallas de vuestros
ordenadores rocco siffredi era conocido
en todo el mundo como el semental
italiano con más de 1700 películas a sus
espaldas se convirtió en el rey
indiscutible de los videoclubs
[Música]
y sin darse cuenta también en todo un
símbolo de la vigorosa economía italiana
durante los años 80 y 90
italia inundaba los mercados mundiales
con productos baratos era algo así como
la china del siglo 20
si algo funcionaba en otro país acto
seguido aparecía una empresa italiana
que hacía lo mismo pero más baratos
[Música]
ejemplo el cine del oeste las películas
de john wayne tenía muchísimo éxito en
eeuu
puesto así que en italia no tardaron en
salir
cientos de productoras de cine que
hacían más de lo mismo pero más barato y
en cantidades industriales
así es como surgió el espagueti western
y lo mismo ocurrió con todo lo demás
cuando donna summer hacía bailar al
mundo entero con sus melodías pegadizas
los italianos contraatacaban con sabrina
aquí había más de lo mismo pero mucho
más barato y mucho más explícitos
y qué me decís del cine de animación a
la vez que disney y estrenaba a lavín en
las salas de cine
la versión barata producida en italia ya
estaba disponible en todos los
videoclips pero esperad un momento
porque no solo hablamos de cultura
barata en general toda la industria
italiana era barata o como se diría en
el lenguaje académico de bajo valor
añadido
italia era especialista en producir ropa
muebles y objetos de plástico si os
compraba es un muñeco de juguete en los
años 90 es muy posible que tuviera la
etiqueta de made in italy ahora bien si
os comprobéis un equipo de música
seguramente dijera made in japan o made
in germany
y os preguntaréis por qué porque los
italianos vivían de vender baratijas en
el extranjero pues fijaros en esta
gráfica aquí se puede ver el valor de la
vida italiana frente al marco alemán
como veis durante los 80 y 90 la lira
estuvo de evaluando se continuamente
en el año 1980 te daban unas 450 libras
por cada marco alemán 15 años más tarde
te daban 1300 liras y la pregunta es qué
significa esto pues que innovar era
mucho más caro para las empresas
italianas por ejemplo imaginad que
tenemos una productora de cine en italia
en los años 80 y queremos producir una
superproducción estilo star wars pero
con efectos especiales de última
generación para eso necesitaremos
comprar ese software de animación que se
vende en japón o esas cámaras especiales
para grabar escenas de acción que se
fabrican en eeuu pero si nuestra moneda
vale menos cada día esas cosas que se
hacen en el extranjero nos costarán cada
vez más y más dinero a esto hay que
sumarle el hecho de que para cada paso
que necesitamos dar tenemos que esperar
meses para conseguir permisos y
licencias del gobierno
[Música]
sin embargo imagina que en lugar de
producir star wars rodamos una película
con nuestro amigo rocco siffredi solo
necesitamos un par de cámaras y una
habitación con una cama y al tener una
divisa débil podemos llegar al mercado
internacional y vender nuestra
producción por un precio mucho más
barato que la competencia donde está el
beneficio en que nosotros en vez de
hacer una gran producción hacemos 1.700
películas lo entendéis bien pues fijaos
en la gráfica porque con este esquema la
economía italiana empezó a crecer a un
ritmo esta vez no voy a decir nacho
vidal ya no sino rock ozzy previa no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
habéis visto bien en los años 90 italia
llegó a ser más rica en renta per cápita
que francia o reino unido en estos años
nacieron miles de pequeñas empresas pero
no se parecían en nada a las de alemania
veréis las mit es tanta alemanas eran
son empresas de entre 50 y 200
trabajadores que tenían y tienen
suficiente economía de escala como para
invertir en innovación
en el caso de italia a sus empresas son
mucho más pequeñas mucho más
tradicionales y en la mayor parte de los
casos mucho más ilegales
[Música]
cuando italia empezó a contabilizar su
economía sumergida que suponen la quinta
parte de su pib la economía creció un
18% de la noche a la mañana y os
preguntaréis pero para qué querrían
innovar los italianos si con este modelo
les iba fenomenal pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
silvio berlusconi es el malo por fin
llegamos al siglo 21 la democracia
cristiana ya es historia y el nuevo y
flamante líder de la derecha italiana es
este hombre que veis aquí que no
necesita presentación
el señor silvio berlusconi
tengo un poco pelo porque mi cerebro es
tan grande que aparta todo lo demás
silvio berlusconi en otro vídeo nos
centraremos más en la trayectoria de
berlusconi pero lo cierto es que el año
2002 no era el mejor momento para ser el
presidente de italia y os preguntaréis
por qué pues porque en el año 2002 es
cuando italia abandonó la línea italiana
y entró en el euro y cuál es la
principal característica del euro
[Música]
whisky no lo controla el gobierno de
ningún país los seguros los emite el
banco central europeo que está formado
por representantes de todos los países
de la eurozona para un país adicto a las
devaluaciones esto es todo un problema
pero esperad un momento porque la
historia no termina aquí recordáis otra
cosa que ocurrió a principios del siglo
21 dejadme que os refresque la memoria
china por fin entra en la organización
mundial del comercio y os preguntaréis
qué tiene que ver lo que pasa en china
con la economía italiana pues mucho
porque el hecho de que china entrará en
la organización mundial del comercio era
todo un síntoma de algo mucho más gordo
y asia estaba inundando los mercados
internacionales porque no sólo hablamos
de china también otros países como
bangladesh o tailandia ya estaban
empezando a vender sus productos y qué
es lo que se fabricaba en asia por aquel
entonces exacto cosas baratas lo mismo
que fabricaban los italianos pero aún
más baratos
[Música]
por aquellos años alemania estaba a años
luz de asia en lo que a tecnología e
innovación se refiere así que sus
productos seguían siendo competitivos
con o sin la competencia china mientras
tanto italia ya no podía utilizar el
viejo truco de devaluar porque a estaban
ya en el euro y ve aunque pudieran
hacerlo no servía de nada contra los
sueldos bajos de los países asiáticos
por ejemplo una de las empresas más
emblemáticas de italia es fiat
en 1990 llegaron a vender más de
1.300.000 coches en europa hoy a duras
penas superan los 700 mil y a duras
penas han sido capaces de vender en
otros mercados otras marcas como bmw no
sólo mantienen sus mercados
tradicionales sino que están creciendo
una barbaridad en china y otros países
emergentes pero esperad un momento
porque la cosa no termina aquí recordáis
que italia tenía un estado enorme con
más de 3 millones de funcionarios pues
eso sigue estando ahí y hay que pagar
en otras palabras que mientras la
economía italiana cae en picado y el
estado lógicamente recauda menos
impuestos los gastos se mantienen y esto
qué significa pues que italia es el
cuarto país más endeudado del mundo su
deuda pública supera el 130 por ciento
de su producto interior bruto y eso mis
queridos amigos de visual política es
una auténtica barbaridad
italia es el siguiente gran problema de
europa
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es sería
italia abandonar el euro para poder
volver a una economía basada en
baratijas o tal vez deberían imitar el
modelo alemán y permitir que sus
empresas puedan innovar podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
qué me decís que no conocéis el modelo
económico alemán hombre por favor pues
hacer clic aquí y podréis ver el vídeo
donde os contamos por qué alemania
exporta más incluso que china y como
siempre no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a visual polític para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartirlo con
vuestros amigos y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]